it's time to prepare the evening iftar
meal but swad and her daughters are in
nourish there's not a lot to be cooked
so access she wasn't able to stock up on
food before Sudan's capital Khartoum
went into lockdown two weeks ago and
while people are allowed to shop for
essential needs during a seven-hour
window she says she doesn't have enough
money to buy everything she needs
Molly things have become very expensive
the prices of oil flour and sugar have
all gone up and it's expensive to even
get to the market we can't afford many
things especially in bulk these days we
managed to have food to break our fast
but sometimes we go to bed without a
full dinner before the next day's fast
the hike in market prices has been more
difficult to bear since her husband
stopped working at daily labour he says
since the lockdown was imposed no one
has called him to offer work before the
lockdown I would earn about a thousand
or 1500 pounds a week by doing
construction in different parts of
Khartoum but now there is no public
transport so I can't go and look for
work and no one wants to hire people
because of the virus the lockdown was
imposed by the government to contain the
spread of the corona virus or covet 19
but even prior to it Sudan has been
witnessing a rise in the price of basic
commodities because of a long-running
economic crisis but the economy has
taken a steeper downturn over the past
few months with the value of the
Sudanese pounds seeming to drop each day
against the dollar prices have become
unaffordable for many in Khartoum
thousands rely on daily labor which is
no longer an option so they're forced to
live with the little they can afford
Sudan's government has announced that it
will distribute basic commodities to
those in need during Ramadan it's also
launched programs offering goods at
below market prices we're distributing
goods and social support to the poor and
the families affected by the lockdown
and this will continue in the coming
days according to the schedule the
support is meant to reach five hundred
and sixty thousand and Khartoum state in
need of support and then there are those
in other categories also in need of
assistance and we will reach them after
supporting the vulnerable so ad and her
husband say they're yet to receive any
assistance for Ramadan and they say if
the Lord
which is due to come to an end in a week
is extended they're not sure how they'll
survive beyond that with no job and no
income Hiba morgan al jazeera cartoon